I have some bad news video games and
movies have been lying to you
suppressors or silences as they're more
commonly known or in fact anything but
silent in everything from movies to
video games the sound of a bullet
leaving a suppressor is always depicted
as when actually it should sound
something like thankfully for our
favorite espionage deliverin
protagonists they mostly exist in
universe with their guns are such
inaccurate portrayals of the real thing
it might as well be considered magic
whether it's protruding from the barrel
of bonds Walther PPK in Goldeneye are
being screwed onto the end of snakes so
called in male Gear Solid the action
genre loves the process
[Music]
how do they do this a fast suppressors a
remain stay in the armory of the modern
assassin or spec ops team and because of
this they're considered to be a fairly
new invention something was created for
the modern era of warfare but reality
though the first commercially successful
firearms suppressor was invented in the
early 1900s by Hyrum Percy Maxim guns
obviously run in his family as his
father created the maxim gun a heavy
duty weapon that was widely used by the
British in their effort to control their
worldwide colonies as well as being
utilized in huge numbers at the Western
Front in World War one where it became
responsible for the conflicts critic
named the machine gun war while his
father's creation was thunderously loud
young Percy was all about keeping things
hush-hush he invented the muffler
commonly used to quiet noisy cars and
then would go on to do the same for guns
with the suppressor the technology was
painted in 1909 and was advertised to
sports shooters with the picture the
suppressor would enhance the shooting
experience by reducing the risk of
hearing damage and noise pollution
advertising focused on presenting the
devices as silencers but a reality they
only served a slightly reduced noise and
muzzle flash again
not silent but quite enough to get 26th
President Teddy Roosevelt to buy one for
shooting rabbits in his backyard without
waking the neighbors while the invention
of Percy's father had gone to make a
huge impact in World War one the
suppressor would influence World War two
in a much more subtle way the Office of
Strategic Services or OSS was an
American organization and forerunner to
the CIA which was founded to conduct
clandestine missions such as spying
sabotage and intelligence gathering
during World War two as its operatives
would be doing missions under a veil of
secrecy they needed a firearm that
wouldn't give away their very precarious
positions that firearm was the high
standard HTML which used it in several
suppressor meaning that it was built
into the weapon instead of screwed on
whenever needed on the British side the
quieter weapon of choice was the welrod
which also featured an integral
suppressor but on the whole was a much
cruder device it was designed to look
like innocuous industrial piping when
disassembled and in perfect conditions
it was a
about as close as firearms can get to
producing the woosh sound for used to
hearing in movies and games the while
rod was used by the British Special
Operations Executive or SOE and there
are rumors that its original purpose was
for it to be air dropped into German
occupied territories to allow for the
mass assassination of SS and Gestapo
over the next few decades suppressors
would be used by military police and
recreational shooters the world over and
they would also get their share of the
limelight in entertainment media such as
movies and now videogames suppressors
undoubtedly make the deafening sound of
a gunshot quieter but they've also
become popular for other reasons so how
does suppressors actually work and how
is action fiction misrepresenting them
the best way to think about sound
suppressors or silencers or moderators
because those are all valid terms and
Firearms is balloons so if you imagine a
balloon full of air or any other gas and
you let it out slowly it doesn't make
much noise might squeak a bit stick a
pin in it it goes bang and it's the
exact same set of physics that apply to
a sound suppressor you're letting the
air out slowly
the silencer specifically targets the
volume of the muzzle blast and it does
that by creating room for those
propellant gases to move into space
expand and expel some of their energy
this space is created by having hollow
chambers separated by baffles this was
Hyrum Percy Maxim's big revelation and
what gave birth to both the car muffler
and the suppressor the level of sound
reduction from a sound suppressor varies
of tremendous amounts and is also quite
subjective depends on the environment as
well on broad average you might reduce
the report of say a pistol with a
suppressor of a given type or regardless
of caliber by perhaps 30 decibels that's
actually a lot they still make a bang
they are used to reduce the report so
it's safer on your ears for one thing if
you're moving and fighting and shooting
and built-up or a closed environment
enemy that you're fighting or shooting
out might not know it's a gun until it's
too late so that's one sort of military
use of suppressors they can reduce
recoil slightly as well they eliminate
flash so they don't just suppress sound
they almost eliminate flash so they have
a valid set of uses but they're not the
the
absolutely silent death dealers that
we've been conditioned to believe now
with all that in mind think about how
suppressors are portrayed in movies and
videogames as movies evolved through the
Golden Age of cinema and people craved
more action and tension and variety in
their stories as well as a greater deal
of heroics from their protagonists the
suppressor became the go-to tool for
raising the stakes
it gave protagonists the opportunity to
throw themselves into what was presented
as an insurmountable challenge or even a
suicide mission
however by taking a suppressed weapon
and employing stealth their odds were
slightly better these conditions
naturally create scenarios that were
more tense for the audience but of
course for that to happen they would
need to believe that a suppressor would
eliminate the sound of a gunshot in
tirely instead of just slightly for the
most part films will go down this Avenue
of complete silence to allow for their
super spies to enter secret bases
undetected but there are some movies
that have portrayed the seemingly
magical tubes of metal and rubber in a
more realistic light zero dark thirty in
the bored films are a couple of notable
examples as is the first John wint movie
however John wick too took some
liberties in its subway shootout scene
in the movie mr. Wickes gunshot sounded
like this but in reality it would have
sounded like this
I think we can all agree that that would
be way less cool while videogames
utilize the same line of thinking in the
creation of their stories and characters
they also have gameplay considerations
to make there are hundreds of games that
feature suppressors in some form or
another for some leading into the myths
much more than others
decades ago in the gaming industry was
still finding its feet the suppressor
was already firmly cemented into pop
culture thanks to its movie appearances
so when they started appearing in games
age-appropriate gamers already knew what
they were and what they could be useful
anyone taking control of surveillance
camera haters Solid Snake or the flat
text embodiment of Pierce Brosnan on the
Nintendo 64 knew this oppressor was
perfect for taking out the enemy
undetected just like in the movies some
press is being presented with the
ability to completely silence bullets is
a necessity for enabling stealth
gameplay and helps to support the
mechanics that are a key to the genre
they're also important for giving
players new gameplay options because if
a silenced weapon was portrayed as being
almost as loud as a non silenced weapon
you're taking away choice and player
agency and interesting gameplay variety
as I'm sure you can imagine sneaking
around outer Haven a snake would be much
less fun without a silencer Sam Fisher
probably wouldn't be shooting out lights
if each gunshot was echoing around
whatever location he's trying to sneak
into and agent 47 would have been shot
long before anyone could sully his good
name with lackluster film adaptations
but not all games are shoe realism
Sumpter the line of that realism and put
a lot of work into making sure their
virtual firearms look and feel authentic
I took some virtual firing ranges to see
how different games handled suppressors
I'm a three being a game that's
applauded for its realism still mutes
down some of its weapons but a silenced
rifle especially a higher caliber one
still has a pretty hefty audible report
when fired the modern warfare series has
changed quite significantly when you
measure the whisper-quiet suppressors of
modern warfare to the much louder
suppress gunshots of the 2019 one of
warfare reboot and well in the stealthy
titles of the Hitman series they may as
well be magic another key consideration
for suppressors in video games is how
they impact balance especially in
multiplayer experiences if they were
treated accurately sticking a suppressor
on the end of your rifle or SMG in Call
of Duty would come with very little
downside the noise the gun makes would
be one small benefit with the various
other performance benefits that come
with using a suppressor would make them
unfair in a video game setting and
detract from the potential variety in
gameplay to deal with this silencers are
used to make guns extremely quiet but
also do things like hide the flash from
your weapon and prevent you from
appearing on the mini-map however the
trade-off is often things like decreased
damage lower bullet velocity or reduced
range for your weapon and if you
remember what I said earlier this
wouldn't actually happen in real life at
least not to the degree that exists in
games the impact of suppressors is being
interpreted in a very narrow and
sometimes exaggerated way but I'm kind
of glad that it is as much as I love
feeling the authenticity and accuracy of
guns in games like armored insurgency or
Sniper Elite and appreciate the
attention to detail at those games have
I also really like when there's gameplay
options available to me so that firing
guns in a virtual space feels varied and
interesting
but I don't give a [ __ ] without the
ability to play a little fast and loose
with how suppressors work it's likely
games like hitman or Metal Gear Solid
wouldn't exist as we know them and it
would mean much less varieties available
to you in games like Call of Duty or
battlefield silencers can also do for
players what they do for protagonists
make them feel like a badass which is
sometimes exactly what you need thank
you so much for watching this very
espionage filled episode of loadout if
you enjoyed it hit the like button
subscribe and let your thoughts known in
the comment section down below